another horrific mass shooting in Texas
we'll talk all about the response by the
media the left and the Republican Party
plus mystery in Saudi Arabia what the
hell is going on over there and some war
in the Democratic Party I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
so not a really dark weekend I mean just
just terrible things happening it seems
all across the planet so well done
everyone
but there is a the worst of all the
things obviously is what just happened
in Texas and I'm going to give you the
the full rundown and why it is that the
left constantly jumps to particular
positions with regards to guns and the
right jumps to different positions with
regards to guess what this says about
their different views of human nature in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at ring
so rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer I have a ring video
doorbell at my house basically what it
does is every time somebody rings the
doorbell
I am notified on my phone I can be 3,000
miles away I can talk to the person I
can activate an alarm I can make sure
that my house is safe even when I am NOT
at home which is great because most of
the people who are trying to break into
your house will try to ring the doorbell
first see if someone's home and then
break in ring make sure they can't do
that anymore
well now ring knows that home security
doesn't end at the front door so they've
created what they call the ring
floodlight cam just like Britain's
amazing tour bell the floodlight cam is
a motion-activated camera and floodlight
that connects right to your phone with
HD video and two-way audio but lets you
know the moment anyone steps on your
property you can see speak to visitors
even set off an alarm directly from your
phone you'll know if somebody is trying
to make trouble in your neighborhood if
you if you get the ring floodlight cam
and also if you have the ring video
doorbell it's the ultimate in home
security save up to one hundred and
fifty bucks off a ring of security kit
when you go to ring calm slash Ben again
that's ring calm / Ben ringing calm
/ Ben then you save off a hundred save
one hundred fifty bucks off a ring of
security kit it's just terrific we've
our family has purchased additional
services from ring because they do such
a wonderful job ring calm / Ben super
user friendly products and at an
affordable price again save one hundred
fifty bucks off the ring of security kit
when you go to ring calm / Ben okay so
here is what we know about what happened
in southern island Springs so yesterday
mmm
yesterday morning at least Pacific time
this horrific story breaks that 26
people have been slain at a church in
Texas 12 to 14 of those were children
pregnant women who are shot basically
there are fifty people in church it
looks like half of them were murdered
and half of them were injured in in this
particular shooting the shooter is a guy
named Devin Patrick Kelly and he is the
gunman he apparently committed before a
week before he committed
the worst math scored a place of worship
in American history he posted a photo
that's according daily beast of a
semi-automatic rifle to Facebook with a
caption she's a bad it's part of a
disturbing picture emerging of the 26
year old who is discharged under
dishonorable circumstances from the Air
Force in 2014 according to Defense
Department records now contrary to some
of the factual kind of accounts that are
going around a dishonorable discharge is
not the same as being discharged under
dishonorable circumstances one means
that your weapon is automatically banned
one does not but in this case it doesn't
make any difference because the reason
he was discharged was apparently for
domestic battery apparently he committed
violence against his wife and their
child in November 2012 and he was
sentenced with the bad conduct discharge
12 months confinement and to reductions
in ranked basic airman according to an
appeals court decision in 2013 that
affirmed the decision against Kelly well
that what that means is that under Texas
state law you'll refuse the capacity for
a concealed carry permit under federal
law you're banned from buying a gun if
you commit a a domestic violence if
you're convicted with domestic violence
assault this was a domestic violence
case so he was banned by law from owning
this gun as far as we know didn't matter
he was still able to obtain in anyway he
answered First Baptist Church at
approximately 11:30 a.m. Sunday opened
fire officials said he wore a ballistic
vest and was dressed all in black so he
was ready to go a law enforcement source
close to the investigation said that the
rifle he used is similar to the one
pictured they couldn't confirm it was
the same rifle he exited the church and
he dropped his rifle and he was then
pursued by a civilian with a shotgun and
died near the city of New Berlin
apparently he died from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound but it was thanks to the
neighbors arriving and shooting at him
so here is here are some of the things
that the neighbors were saying after
after all of this happened here as a
witness talking about a citizen who
stopped the massacre I pulled up to I
pulled up to the intersection where the
shooting happened and I saw two men
exchanging gunfire the other being a
citizen of the community
the shooter of the church had taken off
fled in his vehicle and the other
gentleman came and he said we needed to
pursue him that he just shot up the
church and so that's what I did I just
acted okay and another another witness
talked about this the they talked to one
of the armed citizens who stopped the
massacre here's what he had to say that
suspect crossed the street to the church
Exodus vehicle and began firing at the
church the suspect then moved to the
right side of the church and continued
to fire that suspect entered the church
and continued to fire as he exited the
church a local resident grabbed his
rifle and engaged that suspect the
suspect dropped his rifle which was a
Ruger AR assault type rifle and fled
from the church our local citizen
pursued the suspect at that time okay so
this is what you know there are a lot of
people who immediately jump to gun
control but one of the things that is
that is important to recognize here is
that it was an armed citizen a guy with
a gun a good guy with a gun who showed
up to stop the bad guy with the gun
apparently there are two good guys with
guns who showed up to stop the bad guy
with the gun we still don't know the
details of exactly what happened inside
the church was anyone armed inside the
church was there any security at the
church you know I've been an advocate
for a long time that places of worship
should have armed security there maybe
that's just because I'm a part of the
Jewish community it's very very common
inside the Jewish community to have
armed security we have several security
guards at the place where I worship
every major synagogue in Los Angeles has
many security guards specifically
because of the threat of violence like
this but all of the people on the left
immediately respond by suggesting gun
control is the answer even though the
reality is that it was illegal for this
guy to own guns in the first place
according to the US Code there are
restrictions already on possession of
firearms by individual convicted of a
misdemeanor crime of domestic violence
this is title 18 US Code section 922 G 9
the so called Lautenberg amendment in
the fall of 1996 and it banned the
possession of firearms by individuals
convicted of a misdemeanor crime of
domestic violence in this case he was
domestic violence against his wife and
his child and you know
the fact that he still had a gun
demonstrates that just because there are
laws on the books doesn't mean the bad
people will obey them nonetheless so it
is it is a good thing that there are
good people with guns there to at least
stop him before he could go to another
location and begin trying to to murder
people there just a horrific horrific
event now last week we talked about
whether it was appropriate for President
Trump to talk politically about what had
happened in New York City after a terror
attack and who's talking immigration and
you remember the left said how dare he
politicize how dare he politicized well
they could not wait to politicize this
as always I mean just like the Las Vegas
shooting they could not wait to
politicize so Chris Murphy senator from
Connecticut we sort of considered the
gun control guy on the left after Sandy
Hook he issued a statement saying the
lawmakers quote need to think about
whether the political support of the gun
industry is worth the blood this is just
a lie this idea that everyone who
supports gun rights is is beholden to
the gun industry I was supportive of gun
rights long before we had any
advertisers who are pro-gun I've been
pro-gun rights my entire adult life
virtually everyone who's ever been on
the right has been pro-gun and is not
being paid by the gun industry the
reason that the NRA is so prominent is
not because the gun industry is paying
the NRA is because there are millions
and millions of people who are members
of the NRA who joined voluntarily
because maybe they're afraid that the
left tries to grab guns and suggests the
guns ought to be grabbed every time
something bad happens and they think
well if I were in that church I wish
that I would have had a gun - okay
here's the statement from Chris Murphy
again there's been no talk on the Left
none about why this is inappropriate why
he shouldn't be talking this way he
tweeted quote he put out a statement
said the paralysis you feel right now
the impotent helplessness that washes
over you as a news of another mass
slaughter Scrolls across the television
screen isn't real it's a fiction created
and methodically cultivated by the gun
lobby decides to assure that no laws are
passed to make America safer because
those laws would cut into their profits
again cut into the NRA s profits the NRA
doesn't sell guns
they don't sell guns how would that cut
into the NR a--'s profits if you ban you
know people with misdemeanor violent
crimes against family from from owning
guns which we already have with that
seriously interfere with the with the
NRA and anyway wouldn't even seriously
interfere with the profit margins of gun
dealerships I think not he said my own
is again Chris Murphy my heart sunk to
the pit of my stomach once again when I
heard of today
in Texas my heart dropped further when I
thought about the growing McCobb club of
families in Las Vegas in Orlando in
Charleston a new town who after lived
their own day of horror every time
another mass shooting occurs now one of
the things that I think is worthwhile
noting here before we even go any
further and talk about some of the myths
that are being pervade by folks on the
left with regard to this shooting I
think it's important to note that the
left and right treat terror attacks and
active violence in very very different
fashion the left assumes that human
beings are basically good human beings
are basically good and therefore if you
pass a law
most people will obey that law and that
if you don't pass the law basically
human beings as restrained by the state
are basically good that there won't be a
bad guy who breaks the law and goes out
and gets a gun and therefore because
human beings are inherently good we
don't need to worry about somebody
breaking the law and the best thing to
do would basically be for everyone to
put down their arms on an international
level this leads to the sort of pacifism
that led to the anti-nuke movement the
idea that if we unilaterally disarm we
will create a world without nukes you
saw some of this kind of pie in the sky
stuff from President Obama when he was
Senator Obama the right thing something
different people on the right tend to
think in religious terms and natural law
terms that human beings are capable of
both great good and great evil and then
a bad guy with the gun is separated from
a good guy with the gun by the by the
fact that there's our the by the fact
that one is good and one is bad
they're not separated by the gun they
are separated by the fact that one is
good and one is bad and this is the
problem is how do you group these people
so if the left sees two guys with guns
the left first instinct is to say the
guns should be taken away from both of
them the rights first instinct is to say
well who are they where is the guy on
the right a cop is the guy on the right
good is the guy in the right a preacher
is the guy on the right doctor is the
guy on the left a vagrant with violent
history like we have to separate by
human being whether or not that person
should have a particular capacity the
right tends to look to the vagaries of
human nature when they when they see sin
and evil and the left tends to look to
the implements of violence now I think
there's a halfway position that there
are a lot of people who adopt they say
okay human beings can be good human
beings can be bad but there are some
guns that are too dangerous for even a
good human being to own I think most
people agree with that with regards to
for example fully automatic machine guns
which have been banned in the United
States at least new sales of those since
the 1980s and there's a lot of people
who feel the same way about you know
everyone owning it
I think that's reacting that's
reasonable and rational that's where you
can have reasonable rational discussion
is which weapons are too dangerous that
the risk outweighs the benefit right the
risk outweighs the reward but that's not
the conversation left wants to have the
left wants to have the conversation
basically that all guns are bad because
the same exact weapon that was used to
gun down these people at the church was
probably used by one of these civilians
in order to fire at the bad guy running
away from the scene right the AR the the
Armalite rifle is the is the most
commonly used rifle in the United States
okay it's not an AR does not stand for
assault rifle and I think that it's
important to note all this because you
have to make a decision as a human being
are you worried more about the character
of the people that we produce in the
United States are you worried more about
the capacity of people of any stripe to
get weapons like an AR I'm not
particularly worried about me owning an
AR or my friends the office owning an AR
or millions of people owning an hour I
am worried about somebody who's been
convicted of misdemeanor domestic
violence owning an AR a handgun a knife
or or a toothpick and I think all of
these things are dangerous so I'm gonna
talk in a second about some of the myths
that the left has immediately begun to
purvey online but it's one of them is
anything really dangerous and and
another of them is actually just vile so
we'll talk about that in just a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so
getting prepared for emergencies should
not be tough you know the government
suggests that when you are in an
emergency should have at least some
supply of food available to you right
you should at least have some supply of
food in case you can't get to the
grocery store in case you're blocked in
case the grocery store is sold out in
case the government can't get to you
we've had wildfires and floods fed
tornadoes and hurricanes this season and
that's why it's important they at least
have enough emergency food to get
through a few days that's why my Patriot
supply helps you prepare by giving you a
102 servings survival meal kit for only
$99 one hundred and two serving survival
food kit 99 bucks breakfast lunches and
dinners shipped your home for free call
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen eight eight eight
eight oh three 14 13 or go online to
prepare with been calm again that's
prepare with been calm it lasts up to 25
years in storage folks at the office
we've tried it say it tastes like tastes
good tastes like home cooking prepare
with been calm 888 803 1413 for 99 bucks
you're keeping your family safe it seems
like a no-brainer to me again prepare
with Ben
let's prepare with been calm okay so as
always people run to Twitter to say the
dumbest things they can think of and
basically this is broken down along two
lines line number one is the political
and line number two is the spiritual so
they're sort of intertwined on the left
but there's a slight difference so on
the political side there are a bunch of
folks on the Left like Alyssa Milano who
just put out stuff that is not true
about guns so here's what Alyssa Milano
wrote and again she's now seen as some
sort of political figure which is
amazing I'm not sure by being on charmed
makes you an expert on guns but
apparently you know I have much to learn
about witchcraft and also and also
ignorance about firearms Alyssa Milano
writes there are no background checks on
long guns ar-15s in Texas thanks for the
info Shannon Watts
this is untrue this is a lie there are
background checks on long guns in Texas
in fact this guy went in he actually got
a background check and then he received
a gun anyway even though he was already
federally barred from owning a gun so
yes there are background checks as I've
said there are a universal background
checks across the United States when you
buy from a federally licensed firearms
dealer every federally licensed firearms
dealer every FFL in the United States
must perform background checks on you
before giving you a gun okay the only
ones that are not police this way are
so-called hand-to-hand transactions I
want to sell a gun to my office and so I
can sell a gun to my office without a
without a without going through a
federal background check because then I
would have to go to a store and I'd have
thrown a background check and put the
onus on me and in reality it's
impossible to police except you know on
the way back basically after if Mathis
were to go and shoot somebody
it wasn't me presumably and and then
they would back trace where the gun came
from then they could prosecute me but
prospectively speaking there's no real
way to prevent people from selling each
other firearms in private fire at
federally licensed firearms dealer a
bigger issue because they can be audited
any time by the federal government so
this is just not true from Alyssa Milano
this is also idiocy from from Chelsea
Handler Chelsea Handler again another
one of these political experts who knows
everything there is to know about
politics including the fact that dana
rohrabacher is actually a woman she
tweets quote innocent people go to
church on Sunday to honor their God and
while doing so gets shot and killed what
country America why Republicans well no
no it turns out that the shooter in this
particular case is actually a militant
atheist
if you go to his Facebook page it is
covered with militant atheist slogans
he's apparently on the left on the
political left he went to a church and
and murdered all of these people
apparently he'd been speaking negatively
about religious people for a long time
seven atheist who goes and shoots up a
church and the first instinct is to
blame Republicans which makes no sense
at all the idea here of course if it
were up to Democrats and they would ban
guns all the way now you know I would I
would suffice it to say that if we're up
to the left there wouldn't be as many
people going to church on Sunday to
honor their God period but you know
that's it that's a story I'm gonna get
into in just a second the Second
Amendment to the United States
Constitution provides a right to keep
and bear arms the founders knew that it
was important that human beings be able
to keep arms in order to resist tyranny
from governments foreign and domestic
this is why you're actually mandated in
certain states in the United States in
the early colonies to own a gun in your
home mandated because you had order to
be a member of the militia you had to
own a gun it was your job to obtain a
gun this is not uncommon in Switzerland
they basically have similar laws
essentially but the idea that it's a
Republicans fault when when a bad guy
goes and shoots up a church is really
sick I've never said it's Democrats
fault when a guy goes and shoots up a
congressional baseball game in fact I
defended Bernie Sanders when that
happened this is pretty pathetic
from Chelsea Handler but unfortunately
it's a widespread sentiment and it's
it's not just how about Chelsea Handler
joy read it makes a living being wrong
about everything she blocked me on
Twitter so I had to see this through
somebody else's account
she says enough what the thoughts and
prayers already Paul Ryan had tweeted
out reports out of Texas are devastating
the people of Sutherland spring need our
prayers right now now whenever a
Republican says prayers because
Republicans actually take prayer
seriously folks on the Left lose their
minds how dare they say prayers they
could act right now to stop all this
what are you just gonna pray you just
want to sit around and pray that's your
thing to pray so this demonstrates a
full-fledged failure to understand what
prayer is for on a couple of levels but
joy retweets out enough with the
thoughts and prayers already the Bible
teaches us that faith without works is
dead do something or say nothing so a
first a bit of irony these people were
shot in the middle of prayers they were
shot and they were murdered in the
middle of their prayers and here you are
saying that no one should pray for done
I'm pretty sure that the people who
would be most certain to want other
people to pray for them would be people
in the church who are shot
fairly certain that's the case you know
you didn't hear this sort of stuff after
after the massacre in Charleston South
Carolina the massacre at the black
church you didn't hear a lot of this you
know don't say thoughts and prayers stop
saying thoughts and prayers you didn't
hear it as much because it was Barack
Obama in power and Barack Obama was
saying things like we should express our
thoughts and prayers right then he went
down there he sang Amazing Grace imagine
if Trump went down to Sutherland Springs
and sang Amazing Grace the left would go
ballistic Obama did but because Obama
was pushing their favorite policy
positions that meant that his prayers
were genuine you see because according
to left you're a bad person if you
disagree with them and so your prayers
are worthless we can't we can't disagree
on politics and both pray our prayers
are worthless unless we agree with you
on the politics of the situation so
she's not the only one saying this Keith
Olbermann Keith Olbermann is saying this
too he says
speaker Ryan bluntly shove your prayers
up your ass and do something with your
life besides platitudes and power grabs
okay so number one if you're gonna tell
people not to do something and then what
you probably shouldn't do I say do
something with your life besides
platitudes and power grabs in a tweet
that is purely platitudinous and is
clearly also a power grab I mean Keith
Olbermann would like to grab a certain
amount of power from the American people
by seizing guns that this idea that
prayers if I pray for you that that's
something terrible is just ridiculous so
prayers serve a number of purposes I've
talked about this more in the Bible
segment then I have in the main of the
show but as a religious person who prays
three times daily thrice daily and then
I say prayers before and after my meals
they say blessings before the meals and
after my meals you know we say a lot of
blessings in Judaism so we're constantly
blessing on we're constantly praying in
Judaism it's a thing one of the read
there there are a few reasons for prayer
one of the reasons for prayer is to seal
yourself steal yourself it's for you
less than it is for God God doesn't need
you only doesn't your prayers but you
need your prayers why to steal you for
doing things so the idea that prayer is
only about prayer that we you just you
pray and then you go about your daily
business that's not right one of the the
one of religions sort of basic premises
is that you it is your job as a human
being when you see bad things happening
in the world to recommit yourself to
being a better person
that's what prayer helps you to do it
helps you to confess what you've done
wrong it helps you to realize what you
could do better it helps you realize
that you were created
by a creator who cares about you and
cares about other people and are you
doing the honor to his creation and it
helps you go out and do better things
with your own life second you know there
is a belief in Judaism and Christianity
that God hears your prayers and acts
because of them not as I've said because
God is reactive to you not because God
needs your prayers because you have
changed as a human being and we can
change as a country if we pray together
we are more unified and God responds to
that right that's sort of the idea in
Jewish and Christian communities Stern
Muslim communities as soon as well that
if you pray to God then you are
signifying your subservience to God and
God responds favorably to that so we
actually believe the prayers do
something they're not just spewing empty
words and there is a great irony to all
of these people spewing empty words on
Twitter and saying how dare you talk to
God like there you are talking to your
imaginary sky being but here I am on
Twitter tweeting to no one but I'm doing
something xyq tweeted I promise you my
prayer did more than your tweet my
prayer did more than Keith Olbermann's
tweet here especially because what he's
actually doing is driving the country
apart if you want to create a consensus
based on anything here you can't insult
everybody who prays in the United States
it's like 80% of Americans pray at some
point so that that's just that that's
silliness it's not just him the sort of
scorn but a lot of people on what feel
for religion is pretty powerful again
recognize the irony here an atheist
shoots up a church and the first thing
that people are saying on the left is
stop praying that seems like bad
politics very very bright Stephen King
did the same thing he basically said
it's time to stop praying and he dropped
the G it's time to stop praying it's not
legislating and get rid of the the other
G as well a couple of things one again
it was illegal for this man to hold guns
from all that we know okay so more
legislation would not have stopped that
and two if you really want to show the
scorn that you have for the American
people by dropping G's in praying and
legislate look at those Hicks what
they're praying with their Jesus in
their Bible
those were the Hicks that you that were
shot I mean those were the quote/unquote
Hicks that were shot there were people
who lived in Texas in all likelihood the
parents of these children voted for
President Trump because Texas went
heavily for President Trump it was a
very small town these are people going
on a Sunday morning to pray it's
horrific it's horrific and for people to
sit around ripping their like would you
hear this ever if God forbid a mosque
had been shot up
would you ever hear this a mosket child
would you hear people saying you know
all these people should stop praying to
Allah they stop praying to God for the
fervor for Muslims who were shot of
course you wouldn't hear that
it's just scorn for Christians that
really drives a lot of this and that's
that's really kind of gross okay so in
other news today but I mean but it's not
the only violent story of the day
yesterday or Saturday Senator Rand Paul
was actually attacked on his own
property by a guy who's a registered
Democrat we're still waiting to hear all
the details but the guy broke five of
Rand Paul's ribs five of them okay
that's like that's not a minor injury
you know breaking a rib you can't
actually bind a rib like my dad cracked
a rib one time and it is extraordinarily
painful and they can't put you in a cast
so you're basically walking around
suffering because your ribs are poking
you in the lungs it's really awful and
this guy broke five of Rand Paul's ribs
there may be more to the story we'll
hear about it but if not and this is
just another left attack on a Republican
politician and imagine if Bernie Sanders
had been tackled and broken five ribs
would that lead every newscast ever yes
remember there was a congressional
Baseball shooting that was in the news
for like four days and it was out you
want to look at media biased look at how
these shootings get treated the the
variety of how the shooting is it useful
to the left's agenda is more of a judge
than isn't newsworthy you know Bernie
Sanders being tackled by a right wing
there would be newsworthy and it would
also serve the left's agenda it would
never leave the news Rand Paul gets
tackled breaks five ribs on his own
property and bye-bye Democrat and
nothing nothing I mean I had to find
this on Twitter it wasn't even covered
anywhere it's ridiculous okay so I want
to try to elucidate some foreign policy
news in just a second because it's quite
fascinating what's going on over in
Saudi Arabia but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsor is over at
Skillshare so Skillshare is the best way
for you to make your resume better it's
the best way for you to learn new skill
sets that make you more marketable in
your in your job in your community if
you're looking for a leg up at work
skill share is how you do it
three million members 17,000 classes
it's the Netflix for online learning you
can take classes in graphic design
just a lot of photography social media
marketing it's perfect
it's perfect if you're looking to build
your career or start the side business
of your dreams you know I have taken as
I say water coloring class which helps
calm me in the evenings but beyond that
taking a class in email marketing and
social media marketing all of their
classes at 45 minutes and they are
really excellent very user friendly
Skillshare is giving my listeners right
now a one-month free trial of unlimited
access to over 17,000 classes go to
Skillshare dot-com slash Shapiro again
that skill shared comm slash capiro to
start your free month today skill shared
comm slash Shapiro you can't afford to
sit around think you're gonna be able to
retain your job with your skill set your
skill set isn't good enough keep making
it better with Skillshare comm skill
shared comm slash your career I get a
free month check it out you're gonna
want to continue the service because
it's really terrific
ok so meanwhile mysterious happenings in
Saudi Arabia and it looks a lot like The
Godfather basically okay it looks
essentially like Michael Corleone
cleaning a Michael Corleone II basically
cleaning up cleaning up events after
after his dad dies or I mean Clemens is
going around shooting people in
elevators is basically what's happening
here so over the weekend all of these
events happen I'm gonna tell you the
events and then why I think they're
happening and what I think is going on
we could be five minutes away from a
full on Saudi Sunni versus Iranian Shia
internal Middle East conflict we could
be looking another war in the Middle
East in very short order and there's a
significant possibility the United
States it ends up dragged into it in
some way so I think it's important stuff
so here's what happened over the weekend
so Saudi Arabia is basically being taken
over by a 32 year old young new Prince
this 32 year old guy is considered a
reformer he is a as I say he is a kid
and he has formed a newly formed
anti-corruption committee over the
weekend they arrested at least 17
princes and top officials they basically
went around arresting people the list
includes Prince Alwaleed bin Talal
you've heard his name he's an investor
in Kingdom holding which 95% he's the
owns 95 percent of that it owned stakes
in Citigroup Twitter Apple Fox News
right well the news corp Road which is
the parent company of Fox News after he
was arrested 750 million dollars was
wiped off of his fortune on Sunday at
least 38 former current deputy ministers
have been arrested on accusations of
corruption cNN has obtained the list of
17 people including the formal head of
the royal court
- aah - aah - ivory the Saudi media
mogul Ganon Walid al Ibrahim and Prince
Turki bin Nasser okay so all of this is
basically the the new guy coming in and
arresting all the people who could
potentially pose a threat to him bhatura
soccer is the bureau manager of Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman and he
tweeted the list of arrested
businesspeople three ministers were
removed from their positions tens of
former ministers were detained as part
of the new anti-corruption campaign
initiated by King Salman bin Abdulaziz
al-saud so the new king who replaced
King Fahd after King Fahd died his son
is basically running the show and his
son is this Crown Prince that we are
talking about this Mohammed bin Salman
right because King Salman is the king
over there so the the three ministers
removed were the economy and Planning
Minister the National Guard Minister and
the naval forces commander and they said
that they needed to do this due to the
propensity of some people for abuse
putting their personal interests above
public interest in stealing public funds
and will trace in combat corruption at
all levels according to the release the
32 year old Crown Prince does have the
authority to investigate arrest issue
travel bans freeze the assets of those
it finds corrupt so in the last few
months his ease some restrictions on
women he's supposedly a moderate
moderniser he's eased some restrictions
on women he's allowed them to drive for
example and he's vowed to destroy quote
extremist ideologies in a bid to return
to a more moderate Islam so he's
considered a reformer and he is making
some moves okay so what are some of the
other moves that he's making I mean it's
really astonishing all the stuff that
happened over the weekend it's really
kind of creepy and astonishing at the
same time Prince Mansour bin Mullen is
the deputy governor of ASEAN province -
major province in Saudi Arabia he's
returning from an inspection tour when
his aircraft was down near ABBA late on
Sunday according to the Interior
Ministry he is dead seven other
officials dead in this helicopter crash
why does that matter
because this guy is basically the lead
rival to this Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman so it's obviously an attempt to
submit power and if you know this is
suspicious as it looks this this
particular province exists on the kind
of southernmost tip of Saudi Arabia
Yemen exists just to the south will talk
about Yemen in just a second because
that's that's you know important - and
there's news out of there as well
basically the
Skye's father the guy who is just killed
I mean it looks like I would say
suspicion is that he was murdered you
know helicopters don't randomly go down
in the middle of a purge that this guy's
father was the lead rival to the kid to
King Salman so Prince Mansour bin mu
Curran was kind of the the next heir to
the throne if the other guy had gotten
picked okay so that's another thing
that's happened meanwhile Saudi Arabia
is accusing Yemen of firing an Iranian
ballistic missile into Saudi Arabia
oh very odd okay so they're they're
essentially saying that there was
Iranian technology and this missile
fired from Yemen into the heart of Saudi
Arabia they said they intercepted a
ballistic missile over the capital
according to CNN and now they are
accusing the Iranian government of
having provided technology that was in
that missile now Saudi Arabia and Iran
have been in basically a proxy war in
Yemen for at least a couple of years
here it was the US may patriot system
that shot down the missile there have
been about 14,000 civilian casualties in
Yemen 5,000 people killed from beginning
of the fighting into late August and
again it's heavy Arabia's been very
active because they are concerned with
being surrounded by an Iranian proxy on
their southern borders so this also
looks like you know more provocation and
finally this is the final piece of Saudi
Arabia news then I'm going to explain
what exactly the hell is going on here
because this is all very mysterious and
it does have significant ramifications
for the United States the Lebanese Prime
Minister's Ganim saw Saad Hariri okay
his father was murdered by the Iranians
basically his father was it was killed I
believe his in 2005 by the Iranians and
there have been basically a couple of
revolutions one called the Cedar
Revolution that was a response to the
Iranian presence in Lebanon Lebanon is a
country for those who don't know just to
the north of Israel and just to the west
of Syria it has basically become a
Syrian proxy state and Iranian proxy
state but the Cedar Revolution was an
attempt to move around out of Lebanon
and in the meantime what has basically
happened is that the new Prime
Minister's again I'm sated Hariri who
again is a Sunni guy he's not he's not
he's not Shiite like the Iranians and he
has formed a coalition government
involving Hezbollah as well well now
that is breaking up so the Lebanese
Prime Minister Saad Hariri resigned on
Saturday during a trip to Saudi Arabia
he said his life was in danger it
created a leadership vacuum in Lebanon
hurriediy said he feared an
assassination plot accused a round of
meddling in the region causing
devastation in chaos
he said Iran controls the region and the
decision making in both Syria and Iraq I
want to tell her on and his followers
who will lose in its interventions in
the internal affairs of Arab countries
and the Iranians are accusing the Saudi
Arabian government and president Trump
of coordinating Hariri's resignation in
order to exacerbate tensions
they said the resignation was aimed at
creating tension in Lebanon and the
region the resignation was also meant to
compensate the u.s. for its failures
after the defeat of Isis and her eatery
also points at the Hezbollah which is a
terrorist group that has threatened
Israel as well as Sunni targets and and
Jewish targets all over the world so a
lot going on in Saudi Arabia I'm gonna
explain all of it but for me to explain
it all and elucidate it all and why it's
important to you you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire right now for the
latest news so $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription to daily wire.com
that gets you a subscription you can
watch the rest of my show live on video
you can watch the rest of Michael Moses
show live on video Andrew Clayton's show
live on video all worthwhile
plus you can be part of my mailbag on
Fridays also if you get the annual
subscription then you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels $99 a
year so you save off the monthly
subscription the leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr I see people tweeting it at
me because they love it so much as well
they should since it is magnificent what
a piece of hardware this is 99 bucks a
year it gets you the annual subscription
plus this and there will be discounts in
the Shapiro store which as I say you
will be coming in the near future also
be sure to tune in to watch our next
episode of the conversation on Tuesday
November 14th at 5 p.m. Eastern
featuring the godless Michael Noel's
that's not true Mike Michael is a
religious guy but the the God forsaken
Michael is that fair maybe okay God
forsaken Michael's conversation will
stream live on The Daily wire Facebook
page and the daily wire YouTube channel
it's free to watch for everybody but
only subscribers can ask the questions
I'm subscribing just so I can ask
Michael questions like why do you still
work here subscribe today to ask Michael
questions and join the conversation as
well go ahead and check it out all the
conversations are a lot of fun I've done
one Clavin stone one Michael's doing one
now so go and check it out
if you just want to listen later
subscribe to our youtube channel or go
over to SoundCloud or iTunes subscribe
there leave us a review we
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so what exactly is happening
in Saudi Arabia so I think what's
happening here is pretty simple Saudi
Arabia has been having significant
problems with maintaining the grip of
the Saudi royal family the Saudi royal
family has been threatened from two
sides and threatened on by the Iranians
because the Iranians hate the Saudis and
they've been threatened by extremists
inside their own country and they're a
bunch of extremists inside their own
country and I'm talking about like Al
Qaeda who have basically been
threatening the Saudi royal family for
years it's one of the reasons that the
Saudis were suspected of giving money to
al Qaeda for so many years is because
basically it was a payoff to a bunch of
terrorists to get them off the Saudi
royal family's back there's been the
suspicion for many many many many years
in any case Saudi Arabia has a bunch of
problems one they're disproportionately
young okay it's a country that is
disproportionately young and male it is
also a country that is
disproportionately poor outside of the
oil wealth of the Saudi royal family
virtually the entire country runs on the
oil industry and the problem is fracking
natural gas advanced technologies all of
these are making Saudi Arabia's oil less
valuable than it once was which has put
the Saudi royal family in some trouble
it's also created a need for the Saudi
royal family to draw close to the United
States we could have a shot of Iran
situation here or basically the
leadership of Saudi Arabia is unpopular
inside the country and out but the
United States is best option is to prop
up the Saudi royal family but the only
way the United States has the capacity
to do that is the Saudi royal family has
to do two things one they need to
demonstrate that they're moderating and
they demonstrate that they're fighting
terror and that they're moderating
inside their own country and they'll
earn sort of the the the respect of the
United States they're hoping the
President Trump will back their play and
that Egypt will back their play and
Israel will back their play because now
they're more moderate and they're moving
away from the extremists right so if
they stop supporting terrorism or at
least members of the family stop
supporting terrorism then this will
benefit the the current Saudi regime so
that's I think number one they have to
mean thing number two is they have to
rally their people against the Iranians
they have to rally their people against
the Shia threat and there is a
threat okay because Saudi Arabia is
again bordered on the south by Yemen and
they're bordered in the north by
countries including Syria as well as
Iran so the fact is that Saudi Arabia is
threatened
and it is important for them to defend
themselves but there is something else
happening here which is that the new
Saudi
trying to use that as an excuse for
preventing the the international border
run I'm sorry the border Syria and Iraq
they they come close to bordering Iran
in any case it is important for the
Saudis to demonstrate this threat
because if they can turn this into a
Sunni Shia fight as opposed to a Sunni
versus Sunni fight then they're more
likely to retain power so that means is
right now they are they're exacerbating
tensions and problem is both sides sort
of have an interest in exacerbating
tensions to a certain extent Iran
actually has an interest in keying down
tensions until the point where they can
maximize the regional power Saudi Arabia
has an interest in ratcheting up
tensions in order to enshrine the
current Saudi royal family with the help
of the United States so could this break
into war you can see a bunch of ways
this breaks into war you could see the
the Houthis in Yemen firing ordnance the
Iran back to fees in Yemen firing
ordnance on Syria on the Saudi capital
again you can see the Saudis going in
full-scale with the help of the United
States and you can see are the Iranians
then moving in to defend their boys in
Yemen you can see a situation where Iran
makes a direct move against again Saudi
Arabia because they say that Saudi
Arabia is threatening them
Lebanon obviously is polarizing so what
is now happening it's not really because
of Trump it's because of a couple of
different forces that have happened the
Arab Spring President Obama's Arab
Spring was a disaster for the Middle
East it emboldened Iran it emboldened
quote-unquote reformed forces in
countries but a lot of those reform
forces are actually Islamist like you
saw in Egypt and so you actually see the
threat of terrorism increased in Saudi
Arabia under President Obama President
Obama polarized the region now you
basically have these regimes on one side
and these regimes on the other okay so
on one side you have Israel Egypt Saudi
Arabia Jordan Jordan and Saudi Arabia
both living on borrowed time because
both of those regimes are basically you
know the the families there that run the
place
are in some serious trouble and then on
the other side you have Iran Iraq which
is dominated by Iran and you have
Lebanon and Syria those are all on the
other side and then Turkey sort of
straddles the center-right Turkey is
sort of Iran friendly but they're quasi
friendly to the Sunnis as well sort of
like Qatar in any case you're seeing the
sides form up for what could be a
significant regional war whether if Iran
goes wrong here Saudi Arabia has every
interest in
in war but only if they had the
assurance of the United States the
United States will back them so this is
gonna lead to some serious conversations
about under what circumstances the
United States would back a Saudi
military move in Yemen the answer is
they would against Iran directly it's
questionable Israel would back it
because it because Iran's nuclear
capacity has to be destroyed would Saudi
Arabia and Israel together go along with
Egypt go after Iran you could see
something like that you could especially
if the United States either tacitly
stays out or moves into back and this
could turn into a significant regional
war if Russia decides to back its
proxies in Iran and Syria so this thing
could explode very very quickly all
because the Saudi royal family is
attempting to maintain power and there
are no good options here okay I can't
say that I think there's a great option
here we do have to back the Saudi royal
family we do there there is no
alternative in Saudi Arabia and so
basically you know we all sort of have
to hope and pray this doesn't break out
in the open presumably the Trump
administration could theoretically tell
the Saudis you're on your own here but
that would only embolden the forces that
want to overthrow the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia and instead established either a
terrorist state or a state that is that
his suit that is Iran friendly both of
which would be worse options so thank
you President Obama for just another
crap situation you handed over to
President Trump meanwhile speaking of
things that President Obama destroyed
the Democratic Party continues to be in
a state of civil war Donna Brazile is
now in a one-woman crusade to basically
wreck the party so she has decided that
she has to go off against Hillary
Clinton Donna Brazile has ambitions to
continue running the democratic party
she wants to move over inside with
Bernie Sanders so she put out a piece
last week that we discussed in which she
accused the Hillary Clinton campaign of
basically hijacking the DNC with debbie
Wasserman Schultz's permission and she
sort of backed off that a little bit
this week for example in her piece she
openly said openly that the DNC had
basically rigged the primaries now she's
saying I didn't find any evidence the
primaries were rigged so here she is
backtracking but that's not what she
said last week George for those who are
telling me to shut up they told Hillary
that a couple of months ago you know
what I tell them go to hell I'm gonna
tell my story I want to tell my story
George because this is a story of a
young girl who started in American
politics at the age of nine who
continues to fight each and every
week of her life okay and she she has
today called the Hillary Clinton
campaign racist and sexist but she's
also sort of trying to back off the the
claim that the primaries were rigged
here's what she said about that you
agree with Elizabeth Warren that the
primaries were rigged I I don't think
she she meant the word rigged because
what I said George as you well know
after I left this show back on July 24th
I said I will get to the bottom of
everything and that's what I did and I
called senator Sanders to say you know I
wanted to make sure there was no riggan
in the process I'm all the rules and
bylaws committee I found no evidence
none whatsoever
okay she that is not what she said last
week right that is now she said quote by
the day I had called Bernie I had found
my proof and it broke my heart is
literally what she said she starts off
this little piece by saying that she
wanted to find out if things had been
rigged should I needed to have solid
proof and so did Bernie she said I
promised Bernie when I took the helm of
the Democratic National Committee after
the convention out get to the bottom of
the process as to whether Hillary
Clinton's team had rigged a nomination
process I needed to have solid proof and
so did Bernie I had found my proof and
it broke my heart now she's saying of
course it wasn't rigged because she
realizes that she overstepped here the
the conversation is actually less about
whether it was written about how much it
was rigged so according to Hillary
Clinton's contract she was only supposed
to receive certain benefits during the
general election process in return for
giving money to the DNC the DNC said
they'd offer Bernie Sanders a similar
deal but Hillary Clinton was already
staffing up the DNC upon signing that
contract so it's sort of a distinction
without a difference team Clinton is now
defendant and they're they're tempting
to defend themselves they sent a letter
from a hundred people who are members of
the team including people like Huma
Abedin and they said that this is not
true they said that Donna Brazile is the
tool of Russian propaganda so it's just
tearing the party of heart which is
glorious to watch they said quote
there's an open letter on medium we were
shocked to learn in the news that Donna
Brazile actively considered overturning
the will of democratic voters by
attempting to replace Hillary Clinton in
Tim Kaine as the Democratic presidential
and VP nominees she said over the
weekend that she actively thought about
replacing this an amazing thing right
she actively thought about putting Joe
Biden on the ticket instead of Hillary
Clinton and and Tim Kaine in the last
days of the campaign this is obviously
or hurts him to move beyond the Clintons
and should
clintons and to end this this whole
Clinton debacle I think that's smart by
Donna Brazile I think the party would be
smart to throw Hillary under the bus
here whether they will or not is another
question they've been clinging to life
here clinging to the hope that Hillary
Clinton will eventually become president
through some sort of weird confluence of
events it's not going to happen you know
it's it is pretty amazing those day as
they tear each other apart Tom Perez
who's the current head of the DNC he
came out and he said that there was an
accusation by Donna Brazile that hillary
basically had a seizure on the campaign
trail and Tom Perez says that's absurd I
have great respect for Donna consider a
friend she's done a lot for the
Democratic Party to charge that Hillary
Clinton was somehow incapacitated is
quite frankly ludicrous Hillary Clinton
was a tireless senator a tireless
Secretary of State and a tireless
candidate okay so the idea again that
Hillary was just fine on the campaign
trail that did not seem to be supremely
true and so they're still debating this
longer Hillary stays in the headline the
better for Trump the worse for the
Democratic Party it's that simple okay
time for some things I like things I
hate and then we'll do Federalist number
two because every Monday now we are now
going through a new Federalist paper so
you will learn more about the
Constitution and the system that our
founders created okay first things I
like
over the weekend I had a chance to go
see a movie instead of seeing Thor I
went to see goodbye Christopher Robin
with my wife that's because I'm a huge
Winnie the Pooh fan that's I've
recommended Winnie the Pooh on the show
before
not just the movie but the book because
the book is just clever and charming the
movie is quite good it's really about
how the the father a mem he created
these books partially as a way to reach
out to his child but partially as a way
to get over his world war one war
experiences and the movies really and
heartbreaking movie and really what it
is more about anything else like you can
read this movie in a really interesting
context with regards to some of the
children who've been abused in Hollywood
because a lot of this movie is about
basically how this kid was the first
Hollywood star because he wasn't it was
before you know movies were really a
huge thing this is early 1920s and
Christopher Robin was turned into a
worldwide phenomenon the kid basically
was pushed out by his mother with the
sort of tacit consent of his father to
become a celebrity and how it sort of
ruined his life
you know I have a child star in our
family in our extended family mara
Wilson who's was quite a good actresses
child and you know I I don't want to
speak for Mara we were very close to
their family obviously my dad and my dad
and her mom we're brother and sister and
they were extraordinarily tight their
entire life
but I think Mar would be the first to
tell you that being a child star in
Hollywood is a very difficult thing and
a lot of children are definitely
mistreated by the Hollywood system in
any case that's sort of what this movie
is about celebrity can really
children here is here's some of the
trailer once upon a time there was a
great war that brought so much sadness
to so many people hardly anyone could
remember what happiness was like but
something happened that changed all that
[Music]
[Applause]
his name is Christopher Robin but we
generally call him Billy a taste see are
millions yeah it helped us to believe in
the good things which one would you like
[Music]
okay so really is more my family drama
than anything else but it's very it's
very well done all the acting is quite
good and it's it's beautiful to watch so
you can go check it out good bye
Christopher Robin won't be in theaters
for very long I do have to say they've
really upgraded a lot of these theaters
they understand the crowds are not gonna
be as big for almost are going to see
Thor or something and so they've put in
like the recliner chairs the full
leather recliner chairs really nice
theater experience now so good for them
for doing that so you can go check out
the movie it's worth seeing okay things
I hate so last night I saw this headline
and I just thought it was really really
funny it was supposedly about how
President Trump had been meeting with
Shinzo Abe a who is the the Prime
Minister of Japan they're in Japan right
now and Shinzo Abe a and Trump had gone
and fed the koi fish alright so they
were going I hate when politicians do
these photo ops but they're feeding the
koi fish the way that CNN cut this tape
what it looked like and this would have
been really funny and what it looked
like was they were both they both had
boxes with spoons and they're sort of
feeding the the koi fish
the the fish food with these spoons
they're dropping it from what looks like
a balcony into this fish pond and then
it looks like according to CNN Shinzo
Abe a is still splitting it and Trump
she's got some patient and takes the
entire box of fish food and just dumps
it over the side this is how CNN showed
it so here you can see for for those who
are not watching there's why you need to
subscribe you can see Shinzo Abe a and
Trump are both given on this that
they're both given a wooden box and now
they're just spooning out fish food into
the pond
right you can see there it just
continues like this and now they focus
in on Trump right they just focus in on
Trump and they and look at how the ki
look at how this is cut right so they
cut away from Shinzo Abe a so you don't
actually see what he does
right they pull out and they're gonna
pull back in on Trump right they pull
all the way back in on Trump so you
can't see what Shinzo Abe a does and
what is Trump too he takes the entire
box and he flings it over the side so it
looked like oh look at that Trump then
that boorish American he just he got
bored and he didn't care and while
Shinzo Abe a was still doing this kind
of patient ritual Trump takes the box
and Chuck's it over the side now listen
that'd be hilarious it would be I mean I
would laugh if Trump did that I would
have thought okay it's such a Trump
thing to do I mean the guy did make hats
with Shinzo Abbott's and making our
relationship even better he made them
hats okay that's like a gift you got for
your girlfriend when you're 14 in any
case but what here's what actually
happened CNN cut the video in in in
order to make Trump look bad the media
ran with it Bobby threw out the fish
food first he actually took the box of
fish food and he threw it out before
Trump did it and the media ran with the
story the Trump had been deliberately
rude absolutely idiotic same thing
happened by the way with regard to
comments that Trump made about Japanese
cars the Trump had said to the Japanese
if you could make some more of your cars
in the United States that'd be great and
people were like well they make lots of
their cars here right we have Toyota
plants all over the United States that
are like 16 Honda plants in the United
States Trump said earlier in the night
that he understood the Japanese made
cars in the United States so again you
want to know why people believe Trump
when he says fake news is because some
of the stuff is just fake news it's just
ridiculous okay time to go through
Federalist paper number 2 very briefly
so Federalist paper number 2 as I say
the Federalist Papers were my Alexander
Hamilton John J and James Madison
Federalist number one was written by by
Alexander Hamilton Federalist number 2
is written by John Jay all under the the
the pseudonym Publius so this is really
about natural rights theory and the
question in Federalist number two is
should we form one country or many
countries this is actually super
relevant now when people are talking
about secession and can we even live
together then what do we have in common
anymore and this is the important thing
to know what the founders thought is
that we should be one country as opposed
to many because we had certain
fundamental principles in common I'm
writing my new book on this what
fundamental principles did we have in
common
should where they write and should we
have them in common now because we need
something to hold us together what john
jay says is that basically the
government was instituted in order to
preserve certain of our natural rights
and we all have to give up certain of
our natural rights to the government you
or so that we can live together under a
government that insures the rest of
those natural rights he says nothing is
more certain than the indispensable
necessity of government and it is
equally undeniable that whenever and
however it is instituted the people must
see to it some of their natural rights
in order to invest it with requisite
powers right so some of those natural
rights include the idea you're enough
pay taxes for example no one can come
and seize your property the idea that
you know you may have to go to a draft
there are certain natural rights that in
a state that in the state of nature
would exist and this is sort of a
theoretical construct the founders
talked about or alternatively the idea
that you were living in the area without
a centralized government you know you
don't have a bunch of family farms that
didn't have a centralized government
yeah Deadwood before the actual
institution of the government that in
that state of nature there are certain
things you could do that you can't do
once a government has been formed right
that's fair and then he says here's why
we should form one country and this is
important for the policies we take now
with equal pleasure I have has often
taken notice that Providence has been
pleased to give this one connected
country to one United people a people
descended from the same ancestors
speaking the same language professing
the same religion attached to the same
principles of government very similar in
their manners and customs and who by
their joint councils arms and efforts
fighting side-by-side through a long and
bloody war have nobly established
general liberty and independence this
country and this people seem to have
been made for each other and it appears
as if it was the design of Providence
that inherited so proper and convenient
for a band of brethren United to each
other by the strongest ties should never
be split into a number of unsocial
jealous and alien sovereignties he's
saying don't have a south in the north
don't have a north east and the south
west instead we should have one country
because here are the things he says we
hold in common common ancestors okay for
the most part this was true of the
people of the United States in the Maine
speaking the same language right so
they're people today we say everyone
should speak English this is one of the
reasons professing the same religion we
have to have a certain common
denominator in terms of religion it
doesn't mean everyone has to be a
Christian but it does mean everyone has
to have respect for judeo-christian
values and the judeo-christian God
attached to the same principles of
government we have to believe in a
limited government instituted to
preserve rights not to infringe upon
them similar in manners and customs we
have to talk to each other in a way
where we can all understand one another
and who button who have fought side by
side through long and bloody Wars right
these are the things we have to have in
common it seems like a pretty good
description what the country
right now and unfortunately all of this
has been dissolved right we're not a
people descended from the same ancestors
because we bring in lots of immigrants
that's fine so long as those immigrants
hold the same principles right that's
more important but they don't always
that is why there are people who say we
need to make sure that immigrants who
come in to the United States
assimilate into American culture we
don't all speak the same language you
know the notion that we can speak
different languages and still get along
very difficult to get along and form a
government together when you don't speak
the same language professing the same
religion when you have people who say
that that judeo-christian values are
worthless the values that the country
was founded upon our worthless backwards
and stupid when they say the prayer
itself is a bad thing instead we need a
government that violates rights there's
a difference in vision it's difficult to
have a country when we have basic
disagreements over these things and when
we don't believe in the same principles
of government very difficult to have one
country that's why people are talking
about dissolution of the United States
now because we seem to be more divided
than we ever have been in these contexts
and then Jayne laments he finishes by
lamenting he says whatever the
dissolution of the Union arrives America
will have reason to exclaim in the words
of the poet farewell a long farewell to
all my greatness this is still true
America a disunited America is a less
great America
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
lots more to discuss plus maybe some
deconstructing the culture I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]